nous avons le plaisir aujourd'hui de
recevoir deux des auteurs les plus
choyés les plus gâtés du théâtre de
boulevard jean poste terme exprès ils
nous expliqueront tout à l'heure s'ils
sont d'accord
en tout cas si les héros où les héroïnes
de potiche 40 carats fleurs de cactus
folle amanda peau de vache les shoots la
reine blanche mais oui madame leblanc
vous en vous un petit peu agacé ou au
contraire mesdames et monsieur vous ont
touché et bien c'est le moment de faire
vos proches ou adressez vos
félicitations à messieurs dans l'ordre
je dirais barrier grédy mais je vais
quand même dire vos prénoms une fois
mais je ne le dirais qu'une fois alors
je vais essayer de répéter ma leçon je
vais commencer par monsieur jean pierre
grédy ne me suis pas trompé et pierre
barrier voilà et si ça ne vous agace pas
un tout petit peu qu'on dise tout le
temps barillet et grédy vous aider vous
vous existez quand même oui mais pas du
tout parce que c'est un autre demande
qu' on a un petit peu resserré et de nom
pour n'en former qu'un seul vous savez
jean pierre pierre on s'embrouille là
dedans c'est terrible on ne s'y retrouve
plus longue barillet et grédy c'est
devenu un label mais c'est secondaire
disait d'ailleurs tout à l'heure vous
disait que l'on dit même plus variés et
grédy on dit barillet et grédy tout
court
voilà voyez ça sera comme si et tous les
autres produits rabat 10 alors nous
allons commencer les présentations avec
madame odette leblanc à la mode est le
blanc très très honnêtement vous
connaissiez les prénoms dans les grès
dit non c'est du manque pas alors madame
leblanc mémorisées monsieur brayer et
voilà que c'est embêtant petit trait
d'union le mépris mais alors madame
leblanc aime rire aime rire au théâtre
de boulevard pour reprendre l'expression
s'est volontairement c'est pas tout à
fait du goût amer c'est beaucoup plus
que ça alors dites-nous en quoi c'est
plus sain je trouve que c'est le reflet
de la vie que c'est exactement ce qui se
passe dans l'existence
sous des dehors très gai très et
quelquefois même un peu olé olé
il ya une vérité profonde c'est très
sain ça c'est dit sans grossièreté sans
animosité aucune sans méchanceté c'est
énorme et surtout à notre époque on
apprécie beaucoup et alors avec beaucoup
de rires malgré tout alors l'émotion et
les reproches que l'on peut faire
quelques fois au théâtre de bouvard
jouant les avocats du diable à savoir
peut-être un peu la facilité c'est il ya
quelquefois une fine à paris une
facilité apparente mais qui en réalité
ne l'est pas c'est certainement aussi
difficile et c'est même plus difficile
de faire rire avec des mots justes et
avec une histoire réelle raconté que de
faire pleurer
adam le père ça n'empêche pas de pleurer
du ray c'est ce que j'ai fait la banda
est ce que vous regrettez madame leblanc
que le théâtre de barrier grédy ne soit
peut-être jamais ne sera probablement
jamais représenté dans une maison de la
culture
mais oui c'est très regrettable au même
titre que d'autres la nommer marc potel
les tourner les images dans les maisons
de la culture vous avez nous venons
quelquefois à la rescousse des maisons
de la culture qui sont assez contente de
nous accueillir retourner parce qu'elle
est leur amène du monde je pense
madame leblanc donc nicole donné tout à
l'heure un certain nombre de titres que
vous mariez vous même à l'instant de
folle amanda quels sont donc les titres
les interprètes qui vous aurez bien j'ai
énormément aimé madame
pour nous que je ne connaissais que
comme meneuse de revue au comme
chanteuse et mon dieu c'était très moyen
non je l'aimé bien sans plus et je dois
dire que d'enfants un mandat elle m'a
bouleversée complètement je suis arrivé
à la fin de votre pièce en pleurant
comme une fontaine je reniflais en même
temps et puis après je me suis dit mais
bon ça se termine admirablement bien
c'est réconfortant c'est la vie est à
nous la vie on aime la vie malgré tout
c'est ce que j'aurais dit ce qu'est ce
que j'aurais fait dans les mêmes
circonstances de mon existence
est-ce que là ils répliquent près
c'était ça mais je trouve ça parfait on
révoquera tout cas demi à bord évoquera
tout à leur folle amanda avec jacqueline
maillan autres et line renaud est ce
qu'en quelque part vous vous retrouvez
je me suis retrouvée totalement
patienter mais évidemment c'était ma vie
comme si j'avais rencontré ces messieurs
et que je leur ai exposé même rencontré
alors gaz et les gestes à l'appui la vie
et c'était saviez vous rencontrer madame
j'ai du mal à me leblanc
une folle amanda qui vous a inspiré ces
pièces je dirais que nous en avons
rencontré plusieurs et que nous avons
fait une synthèse de toutes les folles à
mornac nous avons pu croiser sur notre
route mais l'intérieur selon
l'interprète jacqueline maillan qui a
créé colette renard qui lui joué en tout
et line renaud
amanda n'est plus exactement le même
personnage bien bien puisque vous en
parlez non plus au départ et nous
terminerons les présentations après
dominique andré verret a chargé le
magnétoscope donc nous pouvons l'envoyer
nous allons si vous le voulez bien
et c'est vous qui en avait décidé ainsi
voir les deux ex place la même scène
jouée par les deux interprètes car si
comme je le disais à l'instant
vous donnez l'épaisseur la sensibilité à
vos personnages
un comédien peut aussi peut-être
transformer un personnage alors nous
allons regarder le premier extrait qui
est interprété donc madame folle amanda
par jacqueline maillan
oui nous verrons lien renom du lest
alors nous allons regarder jacqueline
maillan j'espère du moins
mais la basse
allons un flip c'est toi je t'attends un
oui oui tu nous appelles tu d'orly et
pourquoi d'orly
et yann mais je croyais qu'elle devait
rentrer la semaine prochaine elle a
avancé son retour
ah ben oui comme tu dis c'est une tuile
oui ben oui je comprends tu pouvais pas
faire autrement bien sûr mais dis moi tu
pourra déranger pour le week end
oui oui oui oui c'est foutu poids donc
je dis c'est foutu non non non non je ne
tourne pas rond
ces derniers temps j'avais un peu
tendance à oublier que tu es marié voilà
au ce voyage je n'y croyais pas vraiment
non
je peux même te l'avouer franchement j'y
croyais si peu que j'ai même pas
commencer à faire ma valise alors à toi
ta valise était prête pas comme ça tu
pourras partir directement pour la
salvia femme a à gauche présentera on
peut on peut qu'on peut bien rire un peu
de temps en temps non ouais c'est ça
c'est ça passe passe quand tu auras
maman oui mais oui je serai là bas où
veux tu que je sois suis toujours là
nous n'aurons t'en fais pas tout ça
n'est pas bien grand line moi aussi ben
oui au revoir voilà ça c'était donc
jacqueline maillan c'était en quelle
année que ça a été enregistrée je parle
pas de la création vous en souvenez
malins n'ont pas eu directement je
retourne me tromper madame du parquet de
7 8 ans nous perdons plus que ça il ya
dix ans des noms je crois pas non je ne
suis pas certain
[Rires]
je crois qu'il ya chanté environ 6,75 la
création voyait alors donc il ya huit
ans alors est-ce que ça a suivi la
tournée la pièce avait tenu et bien une
bonne saison il a décrites pour
jacqueline maillan elle n'a pas joué du
tout et bien nous allons voir maintenant
justement nous allons voir line renaud
alors ça c'est tout à fait récent
puisque nous avons pu la suivre sur
notre même antenne il y à quelques
quelques mois de ce pavillon oui alors
nous allons voir la même scène
interpréter différemment par line renaud
à l'eau il fut en terre qu'est ce qui se
passe je m'appelle d'orly au quad orly
eliane mai
croyez qu'elle devait rentrer que la
semaine prochaine comme tu dis ça à
cause du nom tu pouvais pas faire
autrement je comprends très bien
je comprends parfaitement philippe
dis-moi tu as quand même pouvoir
arranger pour le week-end
évidemment
tout ça me semble bien compliqué c'est
foutu quoi
[Musique]
ne t'excuse pas fini
ces derniers temps j'avais un peu
tendance à oublier que tu était marié à
vrai dire ce départ tu sais j'y croyais
pas vraiment bien de l'avouer maintenant
j'y croyais si peu que je n'ai pas fait
ma valise toi ta valise était prête
comme ça tu pourras partir directement
pour la maison de sologne avec ta femme
non je suis pas fâché je plaisantais on
peut bien rire me n'ont jamais rien au
sérieux tu devrais le savoir
c'est ça parce que faire quand tu auras
un moment bien sûr que celle en veux-tu
que je souffre je suis toujours là au
revoir filets dont fait preuve tout ça
n'est pas bien grave
[Musique]
il faut dire que sur le plateau on a
reçu vraiment différemment cette même
scène madame leblanc vous étiez en train
de me dire que j'ai joué différemment
elle joue avec beaucoup plus de douceur
et de tendresse que madame hayon que
j'aime beaucoup au demeurant mais qui
est peut-être plus brusques plus brutale
et ajouts correspond sans doute
davantage tempérament vers vous ne
devrez pas plus humaine plus humaine oui
comment la pièce at elle été écrite
alors vous n'avez très regretté comme
jacqueline maillan ou comme une renault
est bien vrai dire je les deux je prédis
fier que les deux on peut l'interpréter
comme quand c'est madame cazaurang qui
parvenaient au niveau des répétitions
oui justement pour win et pour indiquer
un jeu qui vous étonnera toujours
on nous écoute pas toujours enfermé pour
dire que ce comté de votre avis malgré
tout en tant qu'auteur bella jacqueline
souhaitait sur l'été évoluer un peu tu
parles pas alors daguestan lorsque nous
avons formé le projet avec elle de folle
amanda elle souhaitait élargir son
éventail et ne pas être essentiellement
comique elle voulait montrer qu'elle
était capable et d'émotions et même de
petits moments dramatiques
donc ça a été écrit très
intentionnellement avec une
variété de nuances et d'intonations donc
nous attendions quelque chose de
jacqueline qu'elle a donnée avec sa
propre personnalité et c'est toutefois
par exemple l'interprétation ne vous
convenait pas ou bien si dans le cours
justement d'une pièce qui dure très
longtemps vous avez affaire à un
changement d'interprète
est ce que il vous arriverait de changer
des mots ou bien des phrases pour
justement adapté à la personnalité
nouvelle oui oui par exemple puisque
voilà je pense est un cas précis potiche
qui avait qui a été créée à paris par
jacqueline maillan à la fin du premier
tableau de potiche elle fait un discours
et elle harangue la foule des ouvriers
or danielle darrieux a joué le rôle en
tournée brillamment très bien être est
drôlement mais elle ne sentait pas du
tout cette scène est donc l
après l'avoir essayé deux ou trois fois
en tournée elle
m'a téléphoné puisque marié n'était pas
là ce moment là c'est moi qui ai eu
affaire à elle elle m'a dit est ce que
ça vous ennuie beaucoup est-ce que je
peux couper cette ce petit monologue
cette harangue je ne le sens pas je ne
le sens pas du tout et jacqueline était
formidable dans dans cette scène on joue
du oud naturellement koupéla et voilà ça
c'est un cas très continue on n'est pas
les présentations car ça n'est pas
terminé avec madame du par eux mêmes
questions que pour madame leblanc
est-ce que c'est du théâtre de bouvard
le théâtre barrière le boulevard vous
dites dans votre relève ce sont des
chaînes des scènes charmante beaucoup
moins superficielle qu'on pourrait le
penser
qu'est ce que vous entendez par là oui
parce que comme l'a bien exprimé madame
leblanc tout à l'heure je pense que ce
sont des personnages qui sont bien
marqués de chacun de leur psychologie
propres je crois que vraiment messieurs
variés et grédy ont trouvé des si vous
voulez des accents à la fois comique et
humain et ça ça n'est pas ce n'est pas
de sa vie pas facile
le j'en parle un petit peu en
connaissance de cause puisque je suis un
petit peu modestement leurs confrères
mais ce que je voudrais surtout vous
exécrez vd pièce madame mais bouyer j'en
ai créé 20 ou 25 plus que nous et il y
en a qui sont en un acte alors voyez
ayant échoué mais oui je me joue moi
même avec mes amis et j'ai déjà été joué
à bruxelles
mais enfin vous connaissez bien que les
difficultés je lui connais certainement
beaucoup plus que ces messieurs qui
passe assez bien mon nom je n'ai pas
fait un métier et surtout ça j'en ai
fait plutôt un violon dead et je trouve
que c'est extraordinairement exaltant
rien que la chose elle même de penser
une histoire et de faire vivre des
personnages c'est on est comblé déjà on
est comblé vidal est encore plus dense
on y voit pour de bon vous ne faites
écrit ou es ce que vous avez déjà
interprète aussi au sujet créé la carte
presse que vous avez interprété déjà du
mari a grillé je le voudrais beaucoup
mais je vais vous dire une chose c'est
que quelquefois nous n'avons pas les
personnages qui conviennent à la pièce
et nous avons bien failli jouer la reine
blanche un jour et nous n'avons pas pu
faute d'être assez nombreux sur les
nombreuses district et c'est tout à fait
charmant il y à des personnages là
dedans qui me rappelle les personnages
de labiche en leur temps parce que
j'aime beaucoup la biche et je crois que
vous en êtes des héritiers tout à fait
gentil de vouloir dire que la région est
très cher oui et voilà aussi ce que
j'aurais voulu exprimer c'est que vous
n'avez pas sacrifier au style cinéma
parce que actuellement on voit beaucoup
trop de pièces on veut faire du cinéma
sur la scène on veut on a des affaires
d'éclairage extraordinaire on a des
changements de décors c'est toujours au
fond c'est pas la peine y a qu'à faire
du cinéma au fond pourquoi faire venir
des gens moi je trouve que et ça enlève
beaucoup de communication et de chaleur
et c'est pourquoi quand les personnages
sont là avec une intrigue vrai qui
commence et qui fini et on sait quand on
s'en va parce que souvent vous avez une
pièce qu'il est n'est qu'une fresque et
tout mon dieu est-ce que c'est fini
c'est fini oui c'est fini mont royal
adressé à la cour entendra devrait
demander l'avis si vous permettez de
notre benjamin qui est olivier segond
dac 18 ans crois qu'on peut dire votre
âge et qui se destine plus
particulièrement au journalisme c'est ça
oui vous faites quoi en ce moment dans
ce moment je fais des études d'histoire
1 sorbonne vous et qu'est ce qui fait
qu'un garçon de 18 ans a envie de
rencontrer variés crédit parce que je
pense qu'il est important de rencontrer
les auteurs les grands auteurs de son
temps parce que les gens de l'époque de
molière ce qu'ils ont pu rencontrer
molière ont une grande chance
décidément après
mais notre modestie alors mais justement
parce que à l'époque de voler on disait
la pièce est pas tellement intéressante
il était souvent boudé mêmes il a
égalisé avec le roi oui quand même
ça se peut plus aujourd'hui mais il a eu
il ajouté
il a eu quelques problèmes à l'époque
aussi il ya certaines pièces sur est
interdite
alors je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est la
même chose parce que vous voulez faire
rire bien on dit barrier gré disent
c'est pas terrible
ben oui ah bon parce que parce qu'on dit
que le rire c'est un peu vulgaire on
sait pas vrai faire rire je crois que
c'est beaucoup plus difficile que que de
faire pleurer parce que on a toujours
tendance à dont quelque chose de
dramatique en fin dramatique on peut le
jouer naturellement que rire il faut
toujours un peu se forcer et moi je
pense se jouera la pièce de bourvil ou
ça s'appelait la bonne planque et il a
un moment au téléphone qu'elle bourvil
jouer oui il a un moment au téléphone
dans cette pièce
ils rient ils rient et se rire pour moi
je pense que ça a été très difficile
hareng et je pense que rire sur scène ça
doit être plus difficile à rendre que
que de pleurer alors peut-être pourrions
nous poser la question directement à
monsieur variés puisque vous au fond
vous vouliez vous avez toujours voulu
écrire mais vous vouliez écrire des
choses des drames même des drames
historiques a pas particulièrement g
ma première pièce sans crédit a été
jouée au théâtre de poche on pouvait
difficilement difficilement trouver plus
petit mais c'était une pièce sombre
alsacienne en costume et très inspiré de
de mauriac dont j'étais un fervent
lecteur s'est éteinte et vous savez de
un peu de bernanos
c'était très très très loin du don
d'adèle comme au loyer et mes pièces
nouvelles pièces prévues aux tu dois
trouver belle à cette époque là parce
par amitié et ont prévu parce que tu as
des jeunes je crois que vous l'avez
revient aujourd'hui nous la trouverions
un peu un peu de vérité non c'est pas
sûr
écoutez moi je veux nous allons reparler
théâtre dans quelques instants mais
j'aimerais que nos téléspectatrices et
tous ceux qui nous suivent vous
connaissez un tout petit peu mieux
c'est-à-dire connaissent un peu mieux
votre intimité et pour cela nous allons
vont nous rendre chez chacun d'entre
vous avez eu l'amabilité de nous
recevoir
d'abord vous monsieur grédy vous avez
été très aimable de nous recevoir dans
votre petit logement nous expliquons
mais peut-être cher que moi moi je n'y
suis pas allé l'enjeu découvrir avec la
raison les caméras d'henri paul âgées
nous nous rendons date donc d'abord chez
monsieur et ensuite chez monsieur variés
voyez l'appartement la pièce principale
de l'appartement c'est le lit le lieu me
sert de bureau de salon de salle à
manger et de lit je vous l'avez compris
je j'habite ici provisoirement je suis
en transit
j'avais une maison de campagne et je
n'ai plus à la voilà alors tous mes
livres et mes meubles sont au
garde-meuble et j'attends qu'un
appartement qui est en travaux soient
prêts pour m'y installer j'ai beaucoup
aimé arranger les appartements les
maisons mais voilà en tout cas ça m'aura
appris qu'on peut se contenter de de
l'essentiel c'est-à-dire un lit un
téléphone une salle de bain je vais vous
faire visiter c'est pas c'est pas la
galerie des glaces est pas versailles
voilà alors comme le placard était trop
petit j'ai je me suis procuré sept
tringle sur roulettes et c'est ma
garde-robe
tout est là tout est là oui oui tout est
là tout est là c'est très pratique en
général et les placards sont mal éclairé
est large et où j'ai tout sous la main
tiens j'ai trois parapluie doit y en
avoir deux qui ne sont pas moyen d'avoir
un barillet sûrement que jésus lui
piquer sa c'est le coin cuisine vous
recevez souvent vous faites deux langues
non non non je peux pas vous faire un
gigot je peux vous faire du café si vous
voulez mais c'est à peu près tout enfin
on peut il ya tout ce qu'il faut
sauf quand même que le sort est injuste
pour vous monsieur grédy vous avez un
appartement qui est bien petit et nous
arrivons chez monsieur barillet et alors
là c'est est somptueux
je crois que le
la chambre est degré dit que je ne
connais d'ailleurs même par moi même et
que vous avez visité frontier tout à
fait temporaire quand la somptuosité de
mon appartement
ça se résume ce que vous devez cadre est
actuellement dans votre caméra
c'est donc ici que vous travaillez que
vous créez vos qu'est ce que vous
écrivez
depuis une dizaine d'années je crois je
suis un bruit avec les dates mais je
crois que j'habite ici depuis une
dizaine d'années à peu près eh bien oui
c'est sur ce même canapé que nous avons
écrit toutes nos dernières pièces en
général ces crédits qui tient la plume
sur ses genoux nous n'avons pas de
bureau pas de table de travail non oui
c'est là exactement le lieu de travail
pourquoi est ce que c'est vous qui tenez
la plume c'est un pense que je suis
myope s'en douter et maniaque et puis
voilà je ne sais pas pourquoi oui j'ai
l'impression que je te retient mieux
les dialogues face le bazar il est
arrivé à pierre de tenir la plume et
d'écrire lui-même
alors si vous êtes toujours d'accord sur
le thème de vos pièces
est-ce que sur le plan personnel vous
avez des affinités oui les uns des
affinités mais nous avons des goûts très
différents nous avons d'ailleurs des
amis tre nous partageons quelques vieux
amis mais les devis et les deux façons
de vivre sont très différentes
j'aime beaucoup ce grand tableau qui est
au dessus de moi là enfin tous les
objets sont personnelles les objets que
j'ai tu n'aimes pas tout ce que j'ai
aimé pas tout ce que je voulais aussi
presque tout excuse moi aussi mais moi
je ne suis pas du tout un collectionneur
vous savez pas tout chaque objet que
vous vous verrez ici est un cadeau ou un
souvenir je le tiens de ma famille il ya
très très peu de choses que j'ai choisie
ou achetés par où ça cette coupe ce
poisson japonais japonaise oui oui mais
c'est un cadeau de grec vient alors peu
qualifiés 9 ans portera vous avez voulu
s'en débarrasser
je l'aimé beaucoup mais son puissant
comme il voyage beaucoup d'un
appartement à l'autre là il est toujours
sûr de ne voir là est-ce que vous
souhaiteriez qu'il l'ait en force au nom
et que je ne l'aurais pas mis à
l'honneur même pour faire plaisir à des
raids ici je ne la met pas
j'aimais bien aller chez les brocanteurs
il ya longtemps il ya eu une jambe et
une année où des gradients ici n'était
pas là je vous le dirai il a un très
très très grand sens artistique
décorateur comme j'ai pu le constater
chez moi c'est vraiment bien la peine
mais nous reviendrons chez vous je
prenais rendez vous je suis sûr qu'il
aura une surprise
est-ce que vous gardez tous les deux ou
l'un plus que l'autre des souvenirs de
vos de votre travail en commun beaucoup
de vos pièces pour ses lui les archives
les archives c'est pierre
j'ai gardé pas mal de photos j'ai gardé
beaucoup de coupures de presse je tiens
vous avez des scrapbook que j'essaie de
garder à jour et dans lesquels on peut
retrouver à peu près toutes les étapes
essentielles de notre carrière
voilà grâce à ce reportage on en sait un
peu plus maintenant sur l'intimité de
barillet et grédy mais madame leblanc
voulait un petit peu savoir à l'évoquer
dans sa lettre comment se faisait le
travail cette association c'est la
chanson la compréhension oui et puis je
vous demander comment vous
organisez-vous ensemble comment
commencez vous à quel moment commence
que vous ne une pièce où est ce que vous
prenez des notes ou est-ce que
j'observais d'abord comment peut-être
aussi la question que se posent les gens
qui nous regardent comment a commencé la
collaboration entre vous une blague
elle racontera comptait exactement une
blague bon alors pierre écrivait des
pièces sérieuse dramatique comme vous
l'a dit tout à l'heure
moi j'écrivais les dialogues pour le
cinéma va nous commencions locomotion et
un beau jour je nous pour pourrir
nous avons eu l'idée de décrire ce
vaudeville qui s'appelait le don d'adèle
nous l'avons écrit vraiment pour nous
mêmes comme vous madame comme vous
écrivez
en ce moment les pièces voilà vous savez
lancé en huit jours nous avons écrit le
don d'adèle et puis peu près jeu est un
peu plus que les jours mon un traître
atteint plus de 10 jours
bon et ça nous l'avons retravailler un
petit peu par la suite et puis moi j'ai
moi j'ai oublié cette pièce et pierre
qui lui étaient j'ai oublié parce que je
connaissais pas du tout les milieux de
théâtre dans l'iss que lui commençait
déjà et il s'est occupé de la piège et
il est parvenu à la queue
convaincre une actrice qui était aussi
une amie qui s'applique a dit sylvia de
jouer la pièce et c'est comme ça que la
pièce a été jouée j'étais très étonnée
très content mais je suis arrivé comme
les carabiniers quand tout était prêt
pour ramasser le succès et ça a été un
énorme succès oui alors cette nuit vous
vouliez ajouter quelque chose monsieur
mari non je voulais ajouter que gaby
sylvia c'était très très courageusement
battus pour faire jouer la pièce était
une jeune comédienne en pleine ascension
elle venait de créer huit clos il était
fort rien du dont la belle est justement
la la la la cocasserie du personnage et
sa versatilité il avait beaucoup tenté
mais elle a fait quelque chose vraiment
qu'ils méritent un coup de chapeau
elle est allée jouer la pièce en
province parce qu'aucun théâtres
parisiens l'avaient acceptée elle avait
été refusé par tous les théâtres
parisiens que tu une leçon d'humilité
pour les directeurs de théâtre pour
qu'ils meurent parce qu'ils trouvaient
que que c'était ceux ci que c'est cela
en tout cas que ça n'était pas d'être
monté je peux vous dire qu'aujourd'hui
encore la pièce est jouée partout je
n'ai deux mois que nous recevions un
relevé de nos pièces senti figure le
monde attaque alors en 1954 rené-luc
aulas
fellah joue là la montée en direct
puisque c'était le moment des souvenirs
et quelques années plus tard je n'ai pas
la date exacte mais elle a été tournée
une nouvelle fois pour la télévision et
interprété cette fois par marianne mako
je crois par maria pacôme et monique
tarbès voilà vous souvenez vous les avez
vous l'aviez vu man du pauvre madame
leblanc moi j'ai vu marthe mercadier
car tous les pilotes qui avaient refusé
la pièce l'on joué parce qu'elles
répondent bien et nous allons voir en
tout cas un extrait de cette dramatique
qui a été interprété donc par maria
paquin et monique barbès le don d'adèle
deux invités mettez les deux couverts
non merci c'est pas la peine que je les
mette madame et ils viendront pas ce
qu'elle a dit maintenant ça ça m'a
échappé
mais non mais non qu'est ce que vous
avez dit mais non mais j'ai rien dit
messieurs nous avons très bien entendu
vous prétendiez qu'il était inutile de
mettre le couvert de nos invités mais
pourquoi et du coup tu la timide quoi la
concierge vous a peut-être donné un
message non mais je sais pas moi vous
avez une amie en service chez madame
gachassin
alors mais c'est fini même si chez nous
même et non madame votre attitude est
pour le moins bizarre mastic ya sûrement
quelque chose je peux pas le dire
m'enfin c'est simagrées expliqué fous
at-elle mais madame faudra pas me croire
pourtant c'est vrai je les ai vus enfin
vous savez fut qui va mais là ce
monsieur est cette dame là vous inviter
les légats chassa les pieds dans l'eau
oui cachaça les pieds dans l'eau mais
oui monsieur mais où les gens n'ont pas
mais où les saf et vous vivez où lech
commence à là tout d'un coup la com
comme ça que je vois je vais vous dire
une chose ou pas la contrarier
pourtant j'avais bien je m'étais bien et
promis de ne pas dire à madame que je
voyais des genres alors là après tout
les ennuis que ça attire et non alors
oui mais mais mais mais même que j'ai
pas une tare de jeu mais messi si je
vais le faire justement c'est pas de ma
faute c'est une tare inquiétez pas ça
s'arrangera non non monsieur antoine ça
sert qu'à ça arrange rafale je croyais
qu'avec le changement d'air ça
s'arrangerait mais non non non non
peut-être que j'aille au docteur
maintenant c'est pas une excellente idée
tu vois énoncé balle à tanis mokrane
mois il fera comme les gens de chez nous
ceci je racontais à madame johanne
autrefois de notre foi sont pas précis
mais messi mais même que j'ai dû changer
de quartier le les geler
jean je vais pas mettre le nez dehors
sans que les gens viennent me pose des
questions
et tout ça parce que voilà vance des
choses qui vont arriver à aa
autrement dit vous avez le dos de double
fondamentale est pas si on qu'on vous
remercier mais n'ont jamais content
total est une année je suis allé à la
campagne avec mes patrons
c'était dans un château alors en ces
bleds jeu
le village était à 5 km sur le sol je
vous dis ça c'était pour mon vous
montrez là le genre de péquenots y en
avait il y en avait qui m'appelle la
sorcière il ya une vache projet de la
fièvre aphteuse j'avais jeté un sort
le curé me faisait la gueule cette saga
pourtant est drôlement pratique de
couverture deviner le nom non croyez pas
ça parce que si je joue à tout pour les
autres tu vois rien pour moi
alors le père touche l'aigle est le
parapluie
je gagne jamais appris là je ne tire les
cartes ça al'air merveilleux mais c'est
fait c'est toujours en faut l existence
bon même ça me fait quand même le
plaisir de faire votre travail et vous
allez mettre les deux couverts du
monsieur et madame gachassin moi je veux
bien essayer dans les pieds dans l'eau
il peut aller voir la cousine que
mademoiselle solange aps - bien bien
madame non pas tant cela vous désirez
messieurs variés grève india ne dit pas
un mot de son texte
notre texte lauréat vendent bien et ça
doit être désagréable pour des hauteurs
tout de même d'antan des interprètes de
transformer son sont à confusion
non pas contre la la personnalité de
reliques tard basse c'est pas trop grave
même qu'un jour on voulait poser une
question moi je voulais vous demander
quand même si comme vous avez écrit
cette première pièce vous aviez quand
même l'intention de la faire jouer
c'était dans votre dans vos ambitions
non peut-être que tu n'aimes la valeur
pas vraiment japon va pas lui il lui
sûrement ce puisque puisqu'il le il
avait déjà donné une pièce mais moi pas
vraiment à partir de quel moment vous
vous êtes dit tous les deux nous allons
continuer à travailler ensemble de 10
rebonds le temps d'analyser les terriers
sa liste après le succès de continuer
oui les choix après le succès du modèle
tout de suite après à moi après on
recommence et une autre caisse
je sais combien vous traitant les oui je
voulais vous demander est ce que c'est
vraiment difficile après de continuer
comme ça sur la même lancée et d'écrire
toujours des pièces de même niveau qui
foutaient ça fait 32 ans ne me posais
pas la question parce que tout d'un coup
c'est me dis que c'est difficile on va
peut être s'arrêter
tout semblait de plus en plus mais après
un succès aussi un départ aussi
foudroyant
il faut que la seconde pièce soit là
même à la même hauteur nous étions
inconscient à l'époque nous avons écrit
à miami est présenté
les choses sont beaucoup plus tard et
alors amis amis et nous l'avons créé un
an après je crois le don d'adèle se
jouer toujours un très grand succès mais
ça mais ça n'a pas l'existence
incroyable n'est ce pas du don d'adèle
c'est une pièce qu'il avait rarement
reprise qui est qui appartient bien à
son époque
madame du palais madame leblanc disais
tout à l'heure qu'il se retrouvait un
petit peu dans dans les interprètes dont
vous interprète de fond comment sont
venus vos sujets enfin ça le don d'adèle
vous avez c'est peut-être à la source
nous avons carrément pris le personnage
de nos mères tellement il était
absolument sûr dans les familles
bourgeoises cette élection de oui oui
toute mon enfance on change il est
partout milesi et voilà donc ça a été un
des mobiles
moi aussi il ya eu des histoires
d'égypte qui se sont plaquées là dessus
donc nous avons vraiment ça a été nous
nous prenions des répliques et les
répliques que nous entendions fois c'est
si vrai vous m'aviez confié vous m'avez
confié l'autre jour que vous ne vous ne
donniez pas de beaucoup de vous même
dans dans vos pièces vous n'êtes pas ni
l'un ni l'autre des auteurs qui ont
envie de faire passer des idées je veux
dire vous avez certainement comme chacun
d'entre nous des choses qui vous
tiennent à coeur des idées que vous avez
envie de défendre quelles qu'elles
soient
est ce que le théâtre n'est pas un moyen
n'est pas un véhicule pour vous dont
vous vous servirez volontiers pas
vraiment en tournant nous préférons être
le leur fled
aimable de nos semblables des répliques
comprenez en fait on peut prendre mon de
piquer des mécaniques comme ça des
traits de caractère mais à 2
c'est forcément un personnel nous
racontant des histoires vous comprenez
nous sommes des compteurs au théâtre
dans une pièce à thèse même nom que jojo
groupe on peut se livrer dans une pièce
on peut mais c'est pas notre cas et
monsieur souvenir
alors justement vous parlez de livrer
une pièce est ce qu'on peut vous
demander d'écrire spécialement pour une
personne par exemple en pensant le
caractère de la personne est ce qu'on
peut vous commandez en même temps une
pièce de l'acteur oui on veut nous
l'avons fait sophie desmarais nous avons
très souvent écrit pour sophie desmarais
qui était vraiment notre interprète
idéal une pièce comme peau de vache et
est vraiment taillé sur mesure pour
sophie desmarais et je dirais inspiré
par elle même si elle vous donne un
sujet de départ est ce que vous pouvez
un ordi non non non non ça le sujet de
départ qu'elle se les gardent le reflet
de sa personnalité
un petit peu lui veut se plaît à le dire
elle même elle le dit elle même le
reconnaît mais beaucoup de nos amis nous
dit audio mais ça c'est moi c'est moi
vous m'avez on avait pratiqué sur le vif
jamais rien dit parce que vous venez de
dire on a l'impression quelquefois les
contacts avec vos interprètes ont l'air
difficile dans le nord non ils sont pas
difficiles cocktails et qu'on les
contacts sont difficiles je les vois pas
enfin c'est à dire je ne vais pas dans
les coulisses ou mais ça ne nous et ça
nous est rarement d'arrivée et on reste
dort jamais
toujours entretenu des rapports les plus
aimables et amicaux oui avec tous nos
corps et plupart de nos corps vous
n'avez pas réussi à vous fâcher vous
avez refusé des pièces à des acteurs
certains acteurs que vous demandez leur
écrire des rôles et des acteurs nous ont
refusé des pièces en tout cas les
acteurs ont davantage refusé nos pièces
que nous n'avons refusé que des rôles à
des actes
en tout cas une seule y est arrivé lui
aussi un très très grand succès c'est
donc peau de vache ou le rappeler à
l'instant vous l'avez donc écrite pour
sophie desmarais qui a été son
interprète idéal
nous allons voir un court extrait elle
est aux côtés de pasqually
c'est la scène où elle est toute douceur
je crois c'était un personnage très vous
allez nous en parler un peu plus du
personnage après pour ceux qui n'ont pas
vu la pièce où l'avait vu louis blanc
sûrement ya intérêt je vous invite à me
payer des dommages et intérêts 4 et
monsieur collines et vous restez par les
états pareils c'est tout comme
gestionnaire le sera moins votre un
homme animal a encore fait des siennes
et road était avec moi là bas il a dû
échapper à votre vigilance puisque j'ai
trouvé pesant la corrida dans mon pool
disent consternés et pas vous le pouvez
ma meilleure pondeuses y est passé je
vous présente toutes mes condoléances à
garder les siens ne remplacera pas mieux
du joug écoutez monsieur colis légers
une petite brise est très prolifique
je vous l'offre de grand coeur pour vous
dédommager mais elle pourrait le pont
c'est un plaisir quand un héros mais je
vous promets qu'il ne recommencera plus
ça je me vais vite me promener sur toi
monsieur collines et pourquoi je voulais
absolument faire la paire
qu'est-ce que ça qu'une guerre est ce
que ça cache toutes ces belles paroles
pourquoi se quereller au fond vous aide
un très brave homme avait comment
viennent vos tomates cette année et non
tous ont bien rabougri a propos je vous
félicite pour vos dégâts je les ai
aperçus par dessus la haie
ils sont superbes les mauves sur tout et
comme on vend les varices de madame
colline allégé qui désirent au ce matin
offrez-lui de ma part avec mes
compliments à bientôt monsieur colina
siège au problème n'hésitez pas à me
retrouver surtout entre nous les choses
s'arrangeront toujours vous aurez tout
on vous être agréable
est malade ou quoi
savez vous monsieur le cabinet que je
vous trouve très sympathique s'en plaint
enfin je ne serai jamais douter ils sont
pas pour nous enfants à partir de
maintenant ils sont les meilleurs
voisins de mort
l'idée
barry agréé dit je crois qu'il ya
peut-être une chose qu'on peut au moins
sous le menton peuvent au moins vous
remercier ou tout au moins les
comédiennes c'est d'avoir écrit en fait
beaucoup pour les comédiennes car vos
premiers rôles sont souvent des rôles de
femmes ce qui est rare au terrorisme est
rare et appréciable mais alors sophie
beaucoup beaucoup à cause de cette
moscou parce que même quand on n'écrit
pas pour s admis un rôle pour elle nous
pouvons avoir en nous-mêmes toutes
sortes de tendance qu on exalte pour une
occasion pour une autre et je me demande
d'ailleurs si tous les deux vous n'êtes
pas embusqué dans chacune de vos pièces
un petit peu à la manière d'un alfred
hitchcock même encore plus dans chaque
personnage masculin et même aussi dans
les autres parce que je ne sais pas il
ya quelque chose enfin vous êtes présent
séminaire de vouzan défendre et là c'est
le peau de vache c'est la mégère
apprivoisée d'un coup plus drôle
malheureusement expire maintenant
justement des demandes a justement
demandé à madame du passé ne pense pas
aussi encore une fois à molière et s'est
enlisée entre-temps japon la corée où il
va mais ça c'est une tradition pourquoi
peu ce mot n'est peut-être pas très à la
mode actuellement
mais tout de même il y a une tradition
de très bonnes observations
psychologique et comique que vous
conservez qu'il faut absolument
maintenir en france et je crois que
c'est très français
l'esprit français vous le possédez vous
croyez vous à la valeur éducative d'une
pièce passée l'ancien en ciel en scène
flamand cette année sans une
intervention
je ne sais pas la valeur éducative je
crois je crois aux rires oui je crois un
rire salutaire quelques fois
enfin de l'observation des personnages
dans un contexte qui tient quelquefois
un peu de la fable donc exprimé moralité
qui peut-être éducative a évidemment et
dans les dents les spectateurs peuvent
tenir compte ensuite quand ils se
retrouvent quand il retrouve des des
travers qui les ennuie et qu'il est ce
qu'ils essaient même de corriger
peut-être n'y crois pas beaucoup on
retrouve toujours les travers de leurs
voisins mais eux ne se sentent jamais
concerné la fin du set où tu as fait
c'est tout à fait ma course j'étais
affaiblie par ses travers deviennent
charmant à travers le théâtre dans la
vie commune il serait peut-être très
ennuyeux mais au théâtre ça devient
charmant et c'est ça qui est merveilleux
ota
c'est que on a la carte essence c'est à
dire qu'on n'a pas les corvées on a
juste ce qui est agréable aussi bien
dans les défauts dans les qualités
monsieur seconde à vous vous êtes
étudiant en histoire à la sorbonne vous
considérez que marié grédy devait
rentrer air devrait rentrer à la
sorbonne pour rejoindre ce que disait
madame 15e rang tu as maintenant mais
plus tard par c'est pourquoi pas votre
on sera mort mais justement c'est ça qui
est un peu le problème on reconnaît les
gens que lorsqu'ils sont morts alors bon
maintenant je crois pas qu'on qu'ils
auraient leur place quoi qu'on pourrait
faire une allusion mais on n'oserait pas
parce qu'on aurait peut-être passé un
peu pour un idiot parce que de dire oui
c'est tout à fait le type du caractère
par exemple d'adèle en ce moment à las
en radio ce serait mal vu bah oui parce
que franchement déjà parlé d'auteur quoi
pas de ce siècle c'est un peu stupide
est ce que ce n'est pas rétrograde cette
attitude mais si justement mais il faut
peut-être lutté contre sept à dix il en
fait parce que sous prétexte que jusqu'à
présent on a honoré que les gens pion
qui sont morts pourquoi justement ne pas
aller de l'avant dix ans mais on va
prendre des contemporains
on parlera d'eux d'ici un siècle ou deux
peut-être ses talons
il faut c'est dur d'être un fantôme
vous avez lu les mots parlent vraiment
ne recherchons pas les honneurs et bon
alors tout ça tout ça n'est pas très
justement mais vous ne recherchez pas
l'immortalité de vos noms de vos oeuvres
je sais pas j'ai souhaité déjà quand on
pense que le don d'adèle qui a été ça
c'est une joie pour nous un vrai il ya
32 ans
il ya plus de trente deux ans puisqu'il
temps 49 la création du temps danneels
et 20 49 bon et bien que ça a été créé
20 49 que c'est une pièce qui est encore
joué ça je vous avoue c'est reichshoffen
et et ça ça c'est une récompense
alors la sorbonne d'autant plus qu'on
est déjà entrés comme étudiants non
issus de toutes façons de considérer que
dès l'instant où on écrit en est
immortel
même lorsque goûter quand on pense par
exemple que georges brassens en allant
fouiller dans opus a découvert par
hasard un petit poème d'antoine pol dont
personne n'avait jamais entendu parler
et qu'il l'a mis en musique on peut
considérer donc tout écrit est immortel
oui puis quelqu'un de motivé mais c'est
oublier en existe deux heures et puis il
n'y a pas que la france pour vous parce
que vous êtes les auteurs et pleins
phares parmi les auteurs les plus
traduits les plus joués les plus
adaptées à l'étranger 40 carats a été
interprétée par au cinéma par
l'éboulement
comment ça s'est passé ça ça s'est passé
vous avez tout simplement après que la
pièce était jouée aux états unis
les droits ont été achetés pour le
cinéma et le film a été tourné par liv
ullmann nous n'avons pas du tout été
concerné par tout cela est d'ailleurs le
film n'a pas été distribué enfin en
revanche on a vu 40 carats interprété
par ingrid bergman en attaque nous
avions des notes d'ott je crois pour wii
non elle a eu beaucoup de succès elle a
fait le film
ingrid bergman c'est qu'ils ont joué les
choses ça a été son retour à la comédie
les fleurs de cactus en cactus flowers
et elle a eu beaucoup de succès dans ce
film et nous nous étions vus quelques
temps après et aller chercher une pièce
à jouer elle devait jouer une pièce à
londres et elle avait pensé aller mais
beaucoup 40 carats 40 carats qu'est
l'histoire de son héroïne est une femme
de 40 ans n'est ce pas et d' un problème
d'âge qui se pose est l art elle nous
avait dit très très drôle moi nous avait
dit écoutez peut-être si vous changez le
titre de la pièce si au lieu de la clé
40 carats on l'appelait 50 gardes alors
à ce moment-là peut-être le risque reste
à jouer le rôle et que pensez vous
justement des adaptations étrangères de
vos oeuvres
vous avez une ce sont nous trouvons
qu'elles ne sont jamais assez adapté ce
sont presque tous les dirigeants il faut
une bonne adaptation doit presque
toujours être libres et nous nous avions
beaucoup insisté au moment de cactus
pour qu' on en face des personnages
américains s'ils s'en défendent et
beaucoup départ finalement ils ont une
ils ont accédé à notre désir mais on
adapte jamais trop une bonne adaptation
doit être pratiquement une adaptation to
be brought il n'y a pas un folklore ou
et parisiens irma la douce paris mes
attentes et inquiétudes en six tunnels
il vous en parlait en connaissance de
cause car si vous êtes adaptez vous êtes
souvent adaptateur je crois que vous
avez vu olivier seconde à ou en tout cas
vous avez vu des extraits ou lu la pièce
qui est adaptée et qui sait jouer en ce
moment à paris par barillet et grédy
cette pièce de péter nicholson n'est ce
pas qui est chromé 10 patients oui vous
l'avez vu non je n'ai pas vu mais j'ai
vu pas mal d'extrait j'ai lu des
articles
justement c'est très bien parce que
d'après ce que j'ai vu on retrouve tout
à fait l'humour anglais assez froid oui
il est froid
will très grands centres et d'ailleurs
c'est assez loin de nous madame a vu la
pièce bien coûter nous allons d'abord
voir un extrait et puis même cazaurang
en parlera avec vous nous allons donc
regarder cet extrait
nous nous retrouvons les quatre
personnages principaux qui sont en fait
les doubles de même c'est ça c'est la
conscience ou ce que chacun d'entre nous
envie de faire et ne fait pas et ce sont
quatre personnages qui en fait n'en sont
que deux nous nous rendons donc à la
comédie des champs-elysées je voulais te
dire la vie des jeux je voulais tu sache
je ne voulais pas avoir toujours été
fier de la façon dont nous traitions
mutuellement de la confiance que nous
avions l'un dans l'autre
si un jour il devait y avoir un autre
homme que moi dans ta vie je suis sûr
que tu me le dira on ne lance pas du
tout ce que nous avions décidé j'ai dit
que si ça nous arrivait on devrait s'y
ménages et réciproquement
moi j'étais mais là j'ai encore une fois
je suis pour le silence les deux cas
c'est que j'avais eu un amant tu ne leur
ai pas dit pour te détruit il devrait
certainement la vie tu me mène alors
thème toujours un cellulaire lu cette
lettre
la première fois dans le salon de thé
devant la mythique des dollars m ensuite
entourage est ensuite dans le taxi anti
tu l'appelles chéri tout en lui se tait
devenu gege n'oublierez cette
humiliation je ne vois personne d'autre
c'est qu'il ya pire perdre la face à
dire c'est une case qui se baisse des
salaires des autres niasse est une
pauvre vase qui a beaucoup d'amour a
deux amours ce moulin n'était pas le
galvauder ont fait d'amour elle a voulu
faire du mal
si les mamans 28 tirs agnès je crois à
niasse crois qu'elle dorme l'atlantique
avec une seule femme
celle que tu avais justement je me
levais personnes or il se trouve que
j'en connais au moins une autre oui sa
part connu beaucoup d'autres en effet
rmc part des banques et et constitue le
poisson et ferrer continue mais je
mesure de ces choses là j'ai de bonnes
raisons d'en être si urgent
tu te remercie à comprendre combien de
temps faut-il elle lui au nom de dieu
toi et albert ramasser les idéal oui
c'est vrai oui c'est vrai nous sommes
tous des inconnus les uns pour les
autres
ça s'est passé comment ça a duré combien
de temps alors quel effet ça te fait
j'ai pas l'intention de donner détails
mais pourtant il faudra bien ça n'a pas
voté pour moi le coup a porté
nanti pas plus restons-en là ça n'a été
qu'un épisode sans lendemain j'avais
besoin d'une épaule pour pleurer après
quelques verres qui est un voyage que ce
s'est passé vous ici il m'avait ramené à
la maison tonnes et ronnie extinct
devons donc à pleins feux de josé artur
et clément garbisu madame cazaurang vous
avez donc vu comédie passion comment
vous avez ressenti cette pièce est
adaptée
c'est une pièce j'ai vraiment je me
permets de vous dire que j'ai trouvé
l'adaptation d'une grande virtuosité
parce que bien évidemment un texte
anglais qui est parfois humoristique
grinçant à la limite du pathétique ça
doit être en effet assez difficile à
adapter en français mais la très
honnêtement c'est non seulement une
pièce singulière est très intéressante
mais on sent qu'il ya une constante
recherche de ce mois intérieur et que
vous exprimer sur scène par le
dédoublement des deux principales des
deux principaux personnages et il y à un
chassé-croisé perpétuelle justement
entre les personnages extérieurs le
comportement et cet affrontement
perpétuel avec leur double qu'on appelle
bon la conscience qui peut être bon la
mort a levé nantes impitoyable et puis
en même temps cette le côté pervers de
ce que l'on a en chacun d'eux soit et
qui est là à vous tenter et que l'on
veut faire taire que l'on veut
absolument ignorer et qui leur survie
pratiquement tout le temps est
réellement réellement il faut
reconnaître que cette ce set ce double 7
s'est doublée
ce dédoublement omniprésent nous oblige
en même temps à une gymnastique
intellectuelle
bien sûr c'est peut-être ce qui déroute
au départ enfin le peuple et que c'était
effectivement au début je me suis dit
mon dieu mais comme c'est intéressant il
ne faut pas perdre un seul mot de du
dialogue des dialogues et blue is an et
si on est en effet parfois on peut
peut-être y trouver enfin dire eux mais
enfin c'est pourquoi ceux utilisés
quelques mots un peu vulgaire et bien
non voilà exactement c'est cruel mais
c'est tout simplement parce qu'en
définitive il arrive à un moment de
d'exacerbation telle qu'on sent que pour
les personnages c'est un soulagement que
de les prononcer en quelque sorte
comment est-ce que le subconscient vous
pas voilà vous parle il ay la peau les
mots crus le sait exactement et au moins
là dans cette caisse
les doubles en le courage de dire tout
haut ce que les personnages pensent tout
bas
et moi j'ai trouvé ça passionnant est
vraiment bien il est très très bien mais
l'analyse très très lucide éviter non je
ne vous cache pas que je suis consciente
qu'il y a des tas de choses qui m'ont
échappé et que je souhaiterais vivement
la revoir une deuxième fois revenu alors
pour dire les choses clairement que
madame cazaurang on parle si bien
comment se fait-il qu'en france ça ne
soit pas tellement bien reçu pourquoi
est ce que les gens sont désorientés
sont comment l'expliquez vous monsieur
je crois que dans une pièce d'un accès
relativement difficile pourtant là aussi
henri un sourire oui on rit c'est le le
sujet de la pièce vous avez touche un
problème peut-être un peu dérangeant
c'est là qu'on perd quand beaucoup de
spectateurs alors s'il a lu lé ter n'est
pas traitée en farce ou en drame ce qui
n'est pas le cas pour cette pièce
puisque c'est à la limite de la farce et
du drame il y as peut-être un ton un
petit peu dérangeant et c'est très
dommage que le public ne fasse pas
l'effort mais maintenant même qu'elles
ont inscrit à un moment où la pièce que
vous avez suivi il ya quand même cette
griffe maria et grédy effectivement je
crois que parfois on peut reconnaître
mais en fin de prime abord on s'aperçoit
que c'est une oeuvre qui est totalement
différente de ce qu'ils ont également
effacé derrière les auteurs notamment
essayé de le servir au mieux et est
rapidement on n'est quand même pas du
tout étonné que vous ayez eu très envie
d'adapter ce genre de poste d'ailier qui
ça fait différent et on peut lui se et
en plus finalement vous avez trouvé la
manière on n'a que des grosses pierres
de ça cool il faut que les dialogues
soir l'écriture drama de musique très
singulière là n'est ce pas s'associer
avec eux ce que j'ai beaucoup apprécié
également ce sont ces le jeu des décors
et de la mise en scène remarquable
oui vraiment remarquable est alors celle
d'hector en triplex avec un jeu de glace
très symbolique de miroirs vraiment
vraiment je crois sincèrement que c'est
une pièce qui mérite d'être d'un très
beau spectacle donné en visite
mais bien sur wii côté les leur jeune
roi je suis même sûr il est l'heure de
nous séparer
j'aime et oui déjà j'aimerais en vous
quittant vous poser deux questions qui
je sais vont vous agacer mais tant pis
je voulais pose quand même parce que je
sais que chaque fois qu'on vous les a
posées bout de temps encore les mêmes
questions je voudrais vous demandez
peut-être à vous monsieur grédy qui
estimez-vous des deux call put qu'elle
plus de talent lui
ils pensent la même chose de moi alors
je peux lui est ce que vous pensez que
vous auriez aussi bien réussi séparément
aurions réussi différemment nous
n'aurions sans doute réussi l'un comme
l'autre mais tout à fait différemment
une dernière question à vous madame
leblanc comment comment définiriez vous
quand vous le faites très bien dans
votre lettre l'association les associés
que sont xavi que c'était un mariage
d'amour en tout bien tout honneur entre
des messieurs qui s'était donc
rencontrer auteurs tous les deux avec ce
que ça comporte est par la suite dans un
voyage
l'un compte temporisant lorsqu'ils
paient mad excessif dans l'ain ce qui
peut y avoir de trop calme dans l'autre
se complétant pour arriver une parfaite
harmonie et surtout écrivant sous des
dehors légers des roues nous ce que je
disais tout à l'heure et exposant les
réalités de la vie telle qu'elle est et
tel que nous la ressentons et que nous
la vivons dans la plupart des cas et que
nous la mort ce qui vous concerne
et oui exactement et dans un texte
facile il appelle un chat un chat ce
n'est pas un poulet
on n'a pas besoin d'un dictionnaire
comme je l'écris avoue être soit par des
banlieues mais qu'est ce qu'ils ont bien
voulu dire etc
on sort avec une tête comme ça non on a
tout compris et on a tous ressenti et je
crois que c'est avant tout leur coeur
qui parle
merci en tout cas d'avoir laissé par est
le vôtre aujourd'hui merci infiniment
mesdames merci messieurs merci monsieur
barry grédy et après bientôt
dominique quelque chose à ajouter non je
crois que on les retrouvera peut-être
dans une centaine d'années à la sorbonne
d'accord je vous reviendrai sur notre
plateau à ce moment là merci de nous
avoir suivis très bonne après midi au
mercy mercy
[Musique]